it was absolute and fraud, it
began from the moment the amendments were made,
when Putin simply lied to the federal
assembly about what amendments were being made,
secondly, it was a fraud because
the amendments that he made,
they can only be made through a
referendum, he did not make a referendum
and now the constitution is contrary  inside
himself and thirdly, it was a scam,
because the voting that he
announced was not even carried out according
to the voting rules, according to some wild
fraudulent rules in which he could
draw any number for himself with his
id2
of etc.  Putin does not want to be in the eyes of the
international community and in the eyes of the
Russian society another
Central Asian dictator [music] he wants to
have some legitimacy,
he needs this, among other things, so that
he can be invited to the G7,
but as a result of this legitimacy, he
will not get  I could because the vote
was so judicious as a result of
Kalyazin,
he definitely deceives himself and because of
this he makes political mistakes, including external ones
, for example, he is
absolutely and for him it was an absolute
surprise that the Western
community acted as a united front
when the annexation of Crimea was carried out
in his world, this
should not have happened, no more thanks, I
don’t think that
his inner circle will ever be
ready to put pressure on him, but
how adequate will this inner circle be
there in terms of the processes
that occur among the rest of the
security forces, among the rest  society is
already a big question today and it should be
noted  that the pressure that the
west exerts on Putin's
inner circle, of course, also demoralizes them all, the
interface is called to fill your own of
all occasions knew this is coming Albanians hill
vika falls from millions to places and of
the south bridge
like this I once again have no
doubt that Putin  in the international
arena, he
acts with the same gangster methods
that he operates in Russia and which
he learned back in his work in the
KGB and then in St. Petersburg,
this is an absolutely gangster technology and he
created an absolutely gangster
state apparatus and in this regard
he creates situations he creates  problems
and then offers these problems
to solve what in this what to do for those
countries to which he creates problems, it is difficult for
me to advise,
although my personal position when confronted
with bandits of which there were many
unfortunately in my life was such that I
never compromised with
bandits, never for  account say Crete
God Duc and she contract to
work out I  I know two painful
situations that were for Putin in
interaction in personal
interaction
with Western society, the first happened
when
this conference was held in Australia and
Putin was simply de facto boycotted after Crimea
, and in general, the second had a very
serious psychological effect on him,
and again  we encountered this in
a situation of force when all
private armed formations in Syria,
supported in fact by the FSB,
attacked the dividing line and the
oil processing plant and were
defeated in battle, this had a serious
psychological impact, because the
bandits understand force in no way
naturally in a different way  my position is that
if Putin yields, then he will not have
borders during which he will not be
ready to cross further
to yield to bandits is impossible
is possible the dates of your captivity
out sharply we de sancy leader great
stability without any doubt
that initial popularity
that Putin had was the basis  on people's perception of
this very stability, if
Putin had left after his two terms in
2008, he would have gone down in history as a
successful leader of Russia, but now that
since 2014 the Russian economy has been
really speaking down when people have been
six years, in any case, it has not been growing
but rather their well-being is falling very
few people in Russia who
would actually like to maintain such
stability